mais est-ce que ça n'est pas un problème
d'être qu'on ramène françois hollande
après un quinquennat plutôt à sac à
autre chose
est-ce que ça c'est votre problème est
un problème mais c'est à nous de
d'expliquer ce qui a été fait et un jour
il y aura aussi à s'expliquer sur ce
qu'il a fait mais qu'il a créée voilà
c'est un peu est ce qu'il sait très
présidentiel ces attitudes de fond sol
non mais je peux arrêter je pense qu'il
faut il faut toujours partir pour
comprendre ce type de dison de
l'échappée solitaire qui lui est
coutumière il faut partir de son
ressenti ce que le prêt de l'ancien
président république ressent vraiment
très intimement au delà des postures et
de son cynisme il ressent une injustice
il se dit j'ai été mais jugé sur mon
bilan est donc toutes les les occasions
de se rattraper doivent mettre offerte
par par le l'actualité et donc c'est
vrai que cette manière de prendre à la
rigolade
c'est une façon de dire on va voir ce
qu'on va voir je n'ai pas dit mon
dernier mot
ça y est c'est le premier niveau
d'interprétation le deuxième il est plus
problématique c'est à dire que je pense
qu'aujourd'hui la reconstruction
éventuelle du parti socialiste elle est
empêché par ce type d'intervention et
c'est la raison pour laquelle dans les
images que vous venez de montrer le foll
se montre tellement embêté car c'est au
fond pour reprendre le titre d'un livre
célèbre 68 c'est un héritage impossible
pour eux surtout pour le foll qui est en
attente qui actuellement dans la
compétition face à najat vallaud
belkacem pour reprendre le parti c'est
impossible pour eux de se positionner
face à cet héritage là et donc on peut
penser qu'au delà si vous voulez de sa
déception de ne pas être reconnus à la
hauteur des réalisations réels
d'ailleurs de ce quinquennat y en a eu
un
il ya de la part de françois hollande
aussi une démarche si vous voulez plus
ambigu peut-être même plus perverse qui
consiste à casser la baraque de ses amis
socialistes aujourd'hui avec ce type
d'intervention intempestives